finally new rule there's nothing wrong
with not having an opinion on something
especially if you don't know what the
you're talking
about and if you're getting your facts
from Tik Tok and Instagram and Facebook
I don't want to hear your hot take on
asymmetrical Warfare because there's a
term for someone who gets their news
from Facebook
mom
you know among the worst things that
social media ever did was it made
everyone feel they had to weigh in on
every controversial issue or breaking
news story and that's my
job in the olden days people would watch
the evening news and then well nothing
they went on they went on with their
lives but today everybody's got to share
their theory on everything whether it's
trans women on the swim team or whether
dwarves should play non- dwarfs in the
Snow White
movie
hey but has has anyone noticed that the
more time everyone spends telling
everyone else their political position
at everything the more we've been at
each other's throats here's a trend I
would love to see on Twitter No
opinion where people take issues like
the debt limit and climate science and
post I don't know about
this Thursday is Thanksgiving the
cherished yearly celebration when
distant friends and Scattered family
members gather together to fight about
Donald
Trump the other
Butterball but not just Trump will also
argue about abortion and critical race
Theory and guns and prisons and schools
and this year we're fighting about
Israel but here's the thing you're not
actually legally obliged to have an
opinion do you know why the Indians and
the pilgrims were able to sit peaceably
through the first Thanksgiving because
nobody brought up
politics even though I'm sure the
Indians had strong feelings about it
immigration back in the90s Michael
Jordan famously said he stayed out of
politics because quote Republicans buy
sneakers
too and then Kanye said and don't forget
Nazis
but the days when someone could say that
and keep their opinions to themselves
those days are gone big brother says
that having no opinion is not an option
anymore you must participate in this
online circle jerk or you'll
be or you will be seen as an insensitive
prick who's single-handedly obstructing
much needed progress in the world did
you post a black
Square no well that's why there's still
racism
[Applause]
you see here's what it is the the
younger Generations were raised
wrong so they can't stand for a minute
the idea that other people have opinions
different than their own 59% of
consumers now will buy a product or
boycott a product based solely on the
political stance a company takes huh gen
Z consumer need to know if their
spermicide condemns
[Applause]
fighting Disney didn't want to get into
a big pissing match with Rona santis
about sex in grade school but its
employees sure did so they had to now
one side thinks Disney said too much the
other thinks it's didn't say enough we
see this pattern over and over we saw it
with Bud Light when they did add with
the Trans influencer and Magan Nation
thought it was a plot to use beer to
turn them
gay pride month is now a Minefield for
corporations this year Target put up
special rainbow displays which presented
Christians who oppose gay marriage with
an impossible choice either support a
gay lifestyle and go to hell for it or
shop at
coal
[Applause]
and why did I ever need to know that
Chick-fil-A is chicken that's
Christian can't it just be
chicken this is unsustainable it's
unsustainable to politicize everything
means we're always fighting because we
don't all agree and never will and most
people don't want to be forced to say
anything Kylie Jenner posted we stand
with the people of Israel
and then deleted it which is pretty much
the opposite of standing
with one executive who was interviewed
about the pressure companies have felt
to make a statement about the Hamas War
said we're not historians a lot of us
didn't understand the issue very well
didn't understand the history exactly
and I bet you still don't so why not
just shut the up
I don't
need I don't need to be reminded that
span's stretchy pants are Against
Racism I don't care who Fredo Lei stands
with you make bean dip just do
that stop making everything about some
other random deeper when I hear
Astroglide want you to know that they
support
stop you lost
me I don't
want I don't want to I don't want to
live in this annoying world where they
can't drink Bud Light and we can't eat
Chick-fil-A I'm sick of all of it this
Thanksgiving I'm going to make beer
canned chicken with Bud Light and
Chick-fil-A and anybody who doesn't like
it can go themselves Happy
Thanksgiving
everybody